[موسيقى]
اول شيء الشركات التقنيه خلال السنوات
الماضيه لو رجعنا لاخر سنتين ترى ما كانت
فيها ابتكارات جدا كبيره كان في حديث عن
عالم الميته فيرس والواقع الافتراضي وغيره
لكن ما شفنا شيء لكنه قبلها ترى ما في شيء
كل الشركات حاليا تبحث عن المفقود عن
الشيء اللي ممكن هم يسوونه يعني ابل من
فتره طويله تقدم الهواتف الذكيه لكنه ما
قدمت خلال السنوات الماضيه اللي ابتكارات
جدا محدوده فصار في تباطؤ في النمو ما في
منافسه جدا كبيره ما بين الشركات زي اللي
كنا نشوفها في عام 2014 2013 كان في شركات
العامله في نظام الاندرويد والشركات
العامه كان في تنافس كبير واطلاقات وخدمات
وبتكارات مختلفه لكن وصلت الاجهزه الى
نقطه معينه لا يمكن ان نتنبا واش راح يكون
في بعدها
[موسيقى]
معلوميه ترى كل منصات تواصل اجتماعيه
تعاني من قوانين الخصوصيه الجديده اللي
ساهمت في تقليد دقه الاعلانات بشكل بسيط
وهذا ادى ان صار في تخوف عندهم سناب شات
قاعد تخسر بسبب ااا
قوانين خصوصيه جديده وللمعلميه ترا سناب
شات خلال فتره خلال سنوات الماضيه ربع
واحد حققت فيه ارباح الرباح الثاني ترى
محققت فيها وفيسبوك حقق ارباح كويسه لكن
عند انهيارات
[موسيقى]